hello and welcome back to the break room
this is a very special episode as we'll
be doing our live reaction to the
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania trailer
that was just released just recently
during the national championship game no
time for introductions let's drive right
into the trailer we know you see it once
already let's watch it again real fast
here we go
classic buttons
so the other actress
[Music]
do we think they all go in at the same
time it looks like they always sucked it
but differently I think uh Scott goes in
after Cassie yeah he like intentionally
let's go
okay
that's my cat that's my cat that's my
cat that's my channel hashtag that's our
King assistant so we know this is like
this is chronopolis more so yeah
Janet is scared to be there oh Ant-Man
you see how that look was like it was
almost like a camera or something
watching um
so you take your Valentine to go see
this February 17th yeah
you're getting multiple small packages
somebody died this is that I'm going
bye-bye this is that one of us gone
I would oh what is the beginning of a
new dinosaur
oh what is that string cheese Ant-Man
yeah but why is he splitting up like
maybe there's some reality Stone magic
going on here
there is a lot of uh uh infinity stone
color images
the red the Amber but remember the
Infinity Stones themselves are like
Elemental right right so we're talking
time which is a part of the elements
which is an infinity stone right so all
these everything plays plays
he's not super strong he's super smart
he's a strategist you know said his suit
is what does mostly everything in his
brains right and what does she say he
has the power to change the like change
with the timeline yeah yeah you can
change reality I don't think they're all
making it out alive on this one fella I
don't know I don't know that's probably
our big takeaway folks welcome back to
the break room uh we held on today's
broadcast to wait for this trailer
they've made its way to the third
quarter and finally released sometime
yeah sometimes PST
um and if you didn't check it out online
that was the version they posted on
YouTube which is a bit longer than what
they showed yes on TV we got a little uh
they had to get back to that room they
had to get back to the game it was
riveting game right big game uh I'm
Brandon of course I'm doing with Tommy
we have Jay we got Erica Russo hey
internet uh we're having a good time uh
but we won't talk about this trailer I
think the biggest thing to take away
from this
like a lot of questions we're going to
be asking in Phase five is this the end
of Ant-Man is it this was a dark kind of
uh sour noted a little bit this is much
different than the teaser trailer when
it shows that Scott Lang being this
Superstar being recognized the employee
yet was it the Baskin Robbins and
everything he's done the podcast the
Fanfare all this this is telling you
this is somebody's culmination this is
somebody's aim and I'm I've been saying
it here on the break room and many other
places what better way to establish the
big bad of the next two phases of the
MCU
then have him kill off the hero the
protagonist of the movie he first shows
up in you know I also agree that Ant-Man
will probably meet his end in this movie
but I don't think it's the Ant-Man y'all
are thinking of oh Marvel loves getting
rid of the Elder Statesman in their
movies I know where you're going I think
we gonna lose the OG Ant-Man Hank Pym
and that makes sense he was very sparse
in this trailer he was but he was in the
room we know from the old trailer or the
first trailer he also got sucked in when
Janet and Cassie and Scott and Ross
current wash get sucked in so this might
be the end of Hank Femme yeah it might
be I mean this is a conversation we've
been having with like the Guardians
right with this like third Guardians
movie seems like the final movie in that
trilogy what characters could make it
out what characters might meet an end
directions
we could be seeing the same thing here
right this could be the end of the road
Maybe be uh for Paul Rudd for a little
bit now you say we're chairman we also
saw multiple Ant-Man in this trailer
tons of it yeah all over the place is
that a Quantum realm trick this is a
Quantum trick that's just a trick I
think he gonna step it looks like he
steps on somebody now my heart
stop bread
wants him to step on Hope and die
completely out but I think he's killing
Scott right because he even says in the
trailer
I don't have to win we just both have to
lose Scott says that yeah that's a
sacrifice line we just don't say sorry
Cassie though that's probably cut out
yeah that's probably just moving around
and things like that's because he
ordered the wrong type of pizza
sorry gluten-free crust didn't show up
so you're gonna have to she was a
headache when she was in jail that's why
they let her out that's right you can't
keep making these cauliflower pieces we
can't afford these crusts you know and I
do agree that the tone of this trailer
was a little bit darker they didn't use
a pop song you know yeah Goodbye Yellow
Brick Road this time
the the score of the movie it sounds
like what they're using uh and this idea
you know this These Warnings from Janet
and this one that like he can rewrite
existence by just thinking about it you
know we've kind of been talking about
like why is this uh this version of King
in the quantum realm in the first place
to be so powerful why isn't he out
messing up universes but maybe he's got
more control from this point this kind
of like Nexus point of all the universe
is coming together or he's stuck yeah he
could be stuck because there's a theory
that when Wanda does there's a theory
somebody put two videos together and it
was from Loki and I think one Division
and it's the moment Wanda does something
I think she becomes the Scarlet Witch
and does something he who remains he
snaps he's like uh oh that's when he has
his first look when he takes a long
pause it's like if you sync them up
they're the same thing and he realizes
remember he tells Loki and Sylvie if you
think I'm bad my variants are worse and
I can control time to keep my variance
in check meaning Kang is probably
somewhere stuck in chronopolis or just
in a level of the quantum realm where he
can't get out but whatever Cassie does
when she's messing with it and does
something to let him out um
it could be a situation where he's not
necessarily stuck but almost like
Aquaman is the most powerful in water
right yeah Kang is his most powerful in
the quantum realm and where he has more
control more amplification of his powers
like me I'm most powerful at an
Applebee's there you go I'm most
powerful at a LA Fitness quite honestly
I love it under a uh shoulder press
you could build a house with those
shoulders
most powerful well let's go through this
trailer a little bit like Moment by
moment uh some of the things we noticed
in it you know we start out in San
Francisco we've been seeing our whole
time they turn on the machine they get
sucked in blah blah there we go up to
that point uh this one had a lot more
Kang right yeah we saw that the blue
face yeah it's like a mask it's a little
mask which makes a lot of sense she's a
good show a little bit of the show yeah
you were saying like Kang is not like in
the comics like a super powerful villain
no but Jonathan Majors is certainly
ripped enough to be a Powerhouse I don't
think like I don't think you Nerf him
after he got
cover your entire neck being this wide
out though as well well and then we have
like Kang talking about like I can give
you more time time is a big big McGuffin
in this movie you lost five years
remember yes but he he came back and
they've been living you know sure Cassie
but they've been living in you know
restored continuity post blip yeah so
I'm curious as to what time he's excuse
me we will never call it the blip it's
the snapping thank you just now sorry
the snapping post-napping yes he missed
some formative years of her life and now
she's an adult she's capital a adult she
can do what she wants she's being she's
getting arrested right she's like we
don't know what her crime is yet but
presumably it's in the same vein as her
father where like oh she's trying to
write some wrongs right my dad do it so
I want to do it but he wasn't there for
those five years to be like hey you
shouldn't do what I did like I paid a
heavy price it destroyed my family to go
into prison I don't want that for you
even if it's the right thing to do it's
not the right way to do it right and so
we missed those years and it seems like
Kang is missing something as well right
and he needs got to do it this was this
was like an early conversation we heard
that like this movie was about Kang
using Scott to get something yeah and
there's a moment in the trailer where
they're like where he's like I did what
you said or you're going back on the
deal we had a deal yeah and again that's
the whole King being stuck you said yes
he may be powerful in the quantum realm
but again if Scott Lang has to do
something for him outside of the quantum
realm that means Kane can't tentatively
leave the quantum realm because again
there was an entire Avengers movie about
to be called the Kang Dynasty what are
one of the little captions we saw the
beginning of a new dining room there's a
reason he he's trying Kane wants Scott
Lang to get him out of here because you
you can come in and out you understand
this now you figured out how I still
haven't as smart as I am I haven't
figured out how to get out of here so
you need to show do whatever it is that
got you in here to bring me out that's
part of the deal and guaranteed you know
King is like as soon as you do what you
need to do I'm still gonna kill
everybody I just don't care well that's
my theory Jay that this is the dumbest
came yeah this is the dumbest one he's
pretty smart but he's still pretty dumb
when compared to other kids because you
can't figure out how to get out of here
oh that one yeah that's right he's just
too dumb Friends
[ __ ] to get him out uh uh well that
tracks is like black panther too they
need a Rivers machine government
couldn't build it they just stole it
which they do all the time there was
like a very cool moment in this trailer
where all so we see ant-many splits into
another Ant-Man uh Ant-Man if you will
uh and then we see a bunch of them uh
creating a an Ant-Man Tower to reach up
to these golden circles spinning which
something inside of there's a good shot
of it there this of course is a great
callback to the first movie when he's
learning to control the ants make them
work together and build a bridge and all
that stuff oh Anthony Anthony R.I.P
Anthony
[Music]
We join you I guess do ants go to heaven
I don't know
um all ants go to heaven no that's the
new Tupac but all spiders go to hell is
there Heaven foreign
I I don't want to say spinning rings but
it looks like spinning wrinkles or rice
uh and we know that there are those 10
Rings calling out to someone out there
now now we assume they're calling out
into our universe we don't know if those
Rings were calling out into the quantum
realm and what they were doing but do
you think there's any correlation
between those weird rings that he's
reaching up towards whatever Powers
inside of them and the ten Rings
absolutely
[Applause]
it's San Francisco for a reason the
merchandise at Target is like three
dollars now from Changi because we are
not tying it in yet
let's get those clearance stickers off
enough Katie dolls aquafina's got enough
action figures okay
get the simu dials back out there get
simu on the show well and then John I
see you have damage there is that like
the writing that's on the ring yeah
there's like some sort of but that's the
same type of right now it's in the 10
Rings yeah that's the same type
inscription that we see in the post
credit this is
well we connected it to a whole other
Universe now or did you mean Sora on the
half man half tarot actor that lives in
the Savage
I just want everyone to be dinosaurs
that I'm in for that I am in for I think
there's gonna be a lot of savage lands
in this one
I think Kang might have built these
to try to figure out a way to get
outside maybe that's what he needs too
maybe it's not just the machine that
Cassie builds maybe he needs the machine
and those 10 Rings okay because both of
those together will help that's part of
this whatever complex Quantum spell that
keeps him locked in and presumably he's
not escaping to start a bed and
breakfast he's escaping to conquer could
you imagine going to King's bed and
breakfast I mean the breakfast would be
easy bro
it's supposed to be the fluffiest you've
ever had the best in all because I made
you an omelette before have you had the
peppers I thought I fed you already
you're you're an Avenger yeah you would
eventually croquet is at 3 P.M or is it
did you say you wanted a Denver almond
in San Francisco yeah from 12 43 BC I
can give you more time late checkout is
2PM
nowadays 11 but for you we got there
okay we got that if there is a
connection between those Rings you've
seen the trailer and the 10 rings I
think the most interesting thing would
be that that energy around the Rings in
this trailer was that golden energy yeah
which is what the Rings turned to when
shangshi took over right when when we
had him it was blue icy cold blue maybe
those were some sort of that was a
tunnel for him in the past and now it's
been shut off because Xiang Chi changed
the magic around the 10 rings but if
that was the case he would have been
able to come out a long time ago per se
maybe he was coming in and out or well
you mixed you mixed that he had the
tunnel right
he had this tunnel with the ten Rings
right but then you had he who remains
keeping him out now he who remains is
dead but the tunnel shut down so it's
like once one thing got changed okay now
this thing is not working he's like I
just can't get out of here because I'm
the dumbest King I'm the dumbass
but that's the dumbest he's still the
dumbest King he's like the youngest
Mensa member we did get a Super Chat to
you Caprice yeah
saying holy bleep what a trailer and you
know she said the magic words
uh we did see a little Modoc now uh John
has a little segment you saw you didn't
sell Modoc for armor showing his guns
showing off looking strong he's not
showing his energy but yeah yeah not
showing his energy bones uh but but in
his Mass looking strong all that good
stuff oh yeah there it is there he is uh
yeah you see him there looking angry the
Modoc we know pretty well from the
comments looks very similar yeah but if
you look earlier in this trailer you can
kind of see him coming into the room too
he doesn't have the mask on he's in the
background there behind Kang as they're
walking they're walking wait is that a
bald-headed gentleman I remember from a
previous
you know I don't want to wear a yellow
jacket to this situation oh my God I
dare it but it's raining outside it is
raining outside shout out to the guy
they flushed on the toilet yeah so it
looks like Corey stole will be returning
as Botox here which is funny because
when yellow jacket
uh left this this holy plane in the
first movie first his little Armstrong
Gan which was funny and then like
another piece and then he kind of
squelched into a little drop but I love
this idea that he got jumped out of the
quantum realm and his body just got so
mangled that his head's normal size or
big but his arms yeah Kang got him out
you know saying right when he's like oh
I can use you you're smart you're a
science you're a scientist I can use you
and so again this shows you how this is
the completion of the circle for Ant-Man
yeah the first villain was yellow jacket
which they typically do in all Marvel
superhero movies always has the main the
equal or the equivalent band yeah I
guess the opposite Powers Yeah uh
different motions right different
costume but you bring Yellow Jackets
name one other superhero movie the first
Iron Man Iron Monger yeah
I'm just kidding they're all like that
Wonder Woman and cheetah don't do this
so what also with that how uh yellow
jacket got scrunched down to the quantum
realm and now he's here as Modoc
potentially uh Paddington in that evil
Chef yes and they both love marmalade I
think it was kind of like a vecina
situation with stranger things and how
the creation of vechna was like 11 sent
him through to the upside down and he
got all mangled in that process and
became so this is kind of like that with
Ant-Man you know mangoing
into the quantum realm thinking he
killed him back in Ant-Man one but
actually some of the cards around I just
made a super villain I just want to say
whoever's watching this live and when
you go ahead and cut this out every time
Eric does that just make sure you put
Dino Man
well we should have got that out
quick quick uh correction on our end you
could create this letting us know that
they are an old man okay all right well
thank good to know Yuka you do you hey
shout out old man or an old man Gary
Oldman hey not this not this movie uh we
do uh uh uh we also had some other chant
the questions come in Mary Smith asking
how do you think Modoc is related to
Kang in this movie I think we just saved
him right yeah I think he saved as soon
as he got brought into the quantum realm
because again once we see yellowjack and
go in at the end of Ant-Man the next
movie is nothing about that it's just
moving forward and we deal with ghosts
and everything right and then getting
Janet out the quantum realm that's all
we deal with right we don't talk about
Yellow Jacket anymore
anyone would assume he was dead right
that the technology killed him the Red
Skull was dead at the end of Captain
America the First Avenger
it's all connected uh we've got some
more of your questions we want to get to
it more we want to talk about but first
we got to take a couple of our sponsors
today you want to think upside if one of
your goals in 2023 is to save money let
us tell you about our favorite way to do
that upside it's an incredible app folks
anyone who buys gas groceries or dines
out they can benefit from this app is
that you you could benefit from this app
with upside you can get cash back on
purchases you make every day it's
basically cashback for just doing you
what did you dine out of the gas station
oh baby
hey I grew up in the South and some of
the best food you get was at a gas
station that's right you want a fried
chicken gizzard that'll blow your mind
you get it from a gas station oh yeah
outside even offsets inflated prices
we're all done with inflation right now
by giving you cash back on purchases you
might be thinking that's such an
incredible app must be difficult to use
but only a Super Genius like Ken could
use it well it's not in fact it's super
easy to use this app I've used it before
it's great uh to get started you just
download the free upside app you use our
promo code promo code break room and you
get an extra 25 cents back for every
gallon on your first tank of gas so fill
it up all way the first time you use it
next time next all you got to do once
you have this app is you claim an offer
for whatever you're buying on upside
then pay as usual with a credit or debit
card follow the steps on the app and you
get paid back it's that simple uh you
might be thinking oh this sounds like a
credit card rewards program it's like
that but you can earn three times more
cash back with upside so it's better
forget those programs plus upside they
won't sell your personal information to
third parties get out of town what a
treat what a treat what uh upside users
are earning hundreds of dollars a year
that's probably why they have a 4.8 star
rating on the app store which means
somebody's just being petty and not
giving them give them the five stars do
it yourself check this app out for
yourself you don't believe me you're
gonna love it it's great I use it all
the time when we're going to get gas or
getting groceries and get that cash back
download the free upside app and use
promo code break room immediately do it
immediately all right
use promo code breaker when you download
the free upside app and get an extra 25
cents back for every gallon on your
first tank of gas let me think my
absolute passes also sponsoring this
episode please my darling my love mi
amor hello fresh the way I impress the
ladies when they come over you think I
know how to make a seared pork chop I
don't hellofresh does it for me I just
follow directions like putting a Lego
together eating well is at the top of my
mind this month you know it every month
I'm getting on that roller coaster I'm
wearing that Verity classic shirt it's
comforting to know you can always get
top quality with hellofresh ingredients
travel from the farm to you in less than
seven days so you know they're fresh
goodbye Old MacDonald come to my table
hello fresh makes dinner time easy old
MacDonald had a farm e-i-e-i-o and in my
mouth that meal does go Yum Yum Yum Yum
Yum hello fresh makes dinner time easy
with Fast and Furious fresh recipes
hellofresh also has a line of meals
featuring robust flavors and filling
portions
flavors and filling portions that are
ready in less than 15 minutes my God
that's almost I mean that's a that's an
explainer video on Modoc uh length of
time which you'll see later on enjoy
tasting quality Done Quick with recipes
like a Falafel Powerball seared steak
and potatoes and Bearnaise sauce or a
Southwest pork and bean burritos yummy
we here at the break room love
hellofresh you would have just heard me
I used to cook for a family of three
with hello fresh and then I got dumped
and guess what accommodate that I cooked
for a family of one now and the horses
remain the same yeah yeah hello fresh is
America's number one meal kit and you
should try it for yourself I'm fine go
to hellofresh.com break room22 and use
codebreak room 22 for 22. that's free so
meals meals it's a lot of meals three
days for me plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com slash break room remember
you gotta use the code to help us help
you folks code is break room 22.
hellofresh.com break room 22. I love you
very much I love you very much Tommy uh
that's okay I didn't like their meal
choices
I want now Jan DM forever doesn't agree
with us they think I don't think any of
them are going to die it's too cliche
you're too cliches
but I think the fact that we're moving
we're moving forward from this Old Guard
yeah we're
okay the rain's really coming down here
in Winnipeg we're moving forward but
like again we've lost most of the
original Avengers you can kind of put
Ant-Man in that original group he's not
a part of the original six but he's in
that original core he's in the main crew
he's in the main crew yeah and we're
losing a lot of them to build up this
new crew as we go forward so to see
Ant-Man die and then we have cassia's
stature that speaks volumes because
again she's just as smart as Hank right
she does just as much she has the suit
and everything there's no reason for
both again I just wanted to hear the
Scott Lang podcast after I was told
about it on Miss Marvel and we will
never get it bro I don't know we'll see
drop Six episodes of that you cowards
yeah yes
um well one thing that is interesting to
try we're talking about like this you
know I kept up my part of the dealer he
does something for for Scott or for Kang
uh Jay you're saying that like gang's
trying to get out right but he obviously
doesn't get out in this movie so what is
it that Scott is getting for Kang that
he keeps up his part of the deal he does
something and then Kang
backtracks on him does it have to do
with those golden swirly things does it
have to do with the weird tentacle
eyeball thing he's flying into yeah what
can he be doing in the quantum room this
is what it is do you think he leaves the
quantum room and comes back I got the
perfect guy okay so here it is so Scott
Lang has a code for adamandeve.com
but you get three free gifts uh listen
to me hang on I have a thought okay what
if he has to retrieve those Rings what
if he's described what if he's got to go
and get those Rings not the Adam and Eve
ring no that's something early that's
Henry yeah he's got to go
in the quantum it goes out of the
quantum realm goes over to to uh
shangshi and Katie's apartment and uh
like an old school Heist just kind of
like maybe not even Heist maybe he's
like hear me out hear me out uh yeah
that would stink if because they don't
have those three uh three guys back for
as the heisters
yeah she is known and again we know that
Bruce knows who he is uh who else was
there Captain Marvel so of course
you know now they know who Shan Chi is
so Scott would know yeah so Scott would
know hey look I heard about what you did
you probably heard I'm an Avenger like
he'll do all those type of things I need
those 10 rings I can't give you those
words and then maybe he finds a way to
steal
what if Jimmy woo helps him with a magic
trick he's in the movie he's in the
movie maybe that's his maybe that's his
his cross to bear is he's like I'll do
some close-up magic and then he steals
somehow he steals the box of the Rings
because of course we know Sean as he's
gonna use himself is not going to carry
the Rings all to like his like his
father did he placed him in the box so
maybe he steals the box of the Rings to
try to take them back my jewelry yeah
you can't sleep over them on you can cut
yourself in the face
Miss Mack Daddy sending a Super Chat
saying how do you all think Bill Murray
will be involved they did put out a
press release with this movie and here's
what they said about Bill Murray's
character uh with the trailer sorry they
haven't put out the movie yet uh they
bought this press release uh he's
playing a character called lord prylar
k-r-y-l-a-r and they describe him as the
governor of Axia a Bazaar and cushy
Community within the quantum realm so
these are the the Bourgeois Montecito
the quantum yeah yeah this is this is
some fancy stuff you can call him
cowardly or self-centered I'll call them
both greyler unapologetically enjoys the
High Life his status grants him
expensive meals exotic cocktails and
top-notch transportation aboard is huge
pleasure yacht this sounds just like the
Grand Master yeah it seems he and Janet
are old acquaintances but the details
are vague uh and she'd like to keep it
that way Bill Moore Bill Murray portrays
Lord portrays Lord
like how did this entire extra world
come to be with people in the quantum
realm like was it just like the big bang
in the quantum realm that started life
well maybe like accidentally people get
sucked down there through various magic
or messing around with technology
because they could come from any point
in time and there is I mean in the
comics it's the microverse right yeah
just exist in a smaller that's you know
particle sized whatever universe so
there might just be erases and species
of beings that are so tiny they exist in
the micro version so they're racist in
the quad that would be hilarious there
are racists
you have my Quantum real with all that
all lit up we're part of the quagga Army
yeah this is all that seasoning you got
and it's real it's called it's called
Maca well you have Quantum realm great
again
you have these people living in Axia who
are like the rich the Bourgeois sounds
like then there's also the character
that uh actor Katie O'Brien is playing
gentura who is this strong and respected
leader of the Freedom Fighters a group
of displaced inhabitants in the quantum
realm whose lives were turned upside
down by Kang she doesn't have time for
Scott Cassie and their problems and
worse their presence alone puts gen
Torres crew in grave danger we think
these are the people that we saw riding
that like Stingray creatures uh maybe
who are being uh kind of ushered around
remember we saw that dude with like the
light head in one of the earlier
trailers that might be this gang right
this could be like gentura in the gang
uh and they're there to fight Kang uh or
they've been displaced by him it sounds
they're probably trying to say again he
rules the quantum realm with the iron
fist but you have those you have that
Supreme dictator and ruler then you
still have the upper class the bougie
which is Laura krylar and his people but
then you have those who are like we need
to stop all of this the Rebels the
rebels Jimmy we were going to pull a
card from Kings here and die
yeah there's a lot of interesting stuff
in this press release they talk about
like the importance of family and family
uh and the secret this is the fast 10
yeah yeah oh wait Corona is a pivotal
character all right uh like Peyton Reed
said quote we wanted to explore the idea
of secrets that family members might
keep from each other sounds like family
family hope and Hank rescued Janet from
the quantum realm where she lived for 30
years it's easy to imagine hope had her
own ideas about what it would be like to
be reunited with her mom sharing all
these stories but then there's an
emotional wall that gets put in the way
so there's like different levels here
right we have Scott and his daughter who
maybe he feels separated with he wants
that time back they show in the trailer
him remembering uh Cassie from Ant-Man 2
and it's like oh I just want my baby
girl back and now she's mean to me and
calls me dumb it says I'm not cool
anymore it says I'm Jiggy uh
wait wait did you say I'm not Jiggy
have their own issues right like who
knows what Janet got up to down when she
was in the quantum she's allowed to do
whatever she wants I I would assume
after a couple of years she was like
well I guess they're not coming from
music I let a lot of these guys hit it
but I never made eye contact and I guess
not a one yeah well and I still think
there might it might be revealed that
Janet at one point was helping King out
a lot because if she has ties to to
gentura and the crew of Freedom Fighters
it also has ties to Bill Murray's
character that probably means she was in
keng's Inner Circle at some point and
there's another scientist Who's down in
the quantum room and Brandon you know
like a lot of these movies the the the
villain is charismatic and sympathetic
in his Origins and then slowly reveals
their their anger and their in their in
their in their malevolency it's like
there's a chance that like Kang was like
kind of pulling the wool over everyone's
eyes when Janet was down there and was
like I just need to get back to my
family and like we all need to work
together but what he was really doing so
let me ask you this question so are we
getting Nathaniel Richardson ramatet
which origin of this because you know
we're getting Nathaniel Richards who was
from the year 3000 was just
experimenting with time travel and stuff
and got sucked in and then was like oh
or just at the process it got sucked in
the quantum realm where I traveled all
the way back to ancient Egypt I'm a
pharaoh I do the Sphinx right here I'm a
leader Sphinx all these different things
I mean it would be interesting I would
love to see more of the Rama time right
they teased it in Moon night there was a
character who had the symbol on the back
of his jacket it would be interesting if
because we don't know when Moon Knight
takes place in the MCU it exists outside
of any confirmed it's after the uh the
snapping because of course the GRC is
mentioned right they mentioned the GRC
but like they don't really place it with
much more time than that right right it
would be interesting if like the events
of this movie they defeat Kang they
think they defeated Kang but he has in
fact escaped and he escaped to ancient
Egypt and established himself as ramatai
and what we saw Moon Knight actually
takes place after this for a history of
Rama time has been like Back to the
Future into society so that when Scott
or whoever makes out of this movie gets
back it's the same Earth but now there's
a Kang here the man who failed her the
man who was in the book
yes yes or the man from Venus oh yeah
aliens of Venus or whatever it's called
Uh it could be something like that
because this is a movie about like the
secrets uh that we've kept and that we
keep from our family and trying to get
all that back guys call in with your
worst secret there's also we want to
know your family the idea of the friend
Slayer ravona rensslayer from Loki yeah
in the comics is romantically tied
if he this Kang misses her or knows her
or wants to find her maybe ravona was
stolen from this King at some point that
that could be as much as all he wants I
just look hey look I've been horny
Millennia down here you can get whatever
he wants in the quantum realm when he
can't get robonas that's what he wants
the most the lubrication down here
oh my gosh DW asking you to check do you
think the tone of this third Ant-Man
film will be less humorous absolutely
nah it's gonna be it's gonna happen I
think Third x is going to be
I'm saying this trailer is leading us
down that path I think the movie I mean
it's Paul Brad He's not gonna right you
know the first trailer had funny moments
you know but I think everybody keeps
saying because it's Paul Rudd because
this movie has been humorous throughout
it all everyone like I received one of
the comments that says him dying is a
smoke screen everybody keeps yes and I
do agree Hank Pym is out of here because
he's definitely oh him and Jenny may be
going together I could see him Jenny
wanted to stay down there and Hank being
like I'm staying yeah I can see that but
I really think it's like cocoon this one
has to take this one has to take a turn
dark in order to set up his seriousness
yes how's the series how Tang he is
that's the one thing people keep
forgetting and I understand where
everybody's coming like no they don't
want the hero to die but in order for
this guy not to to be just any other bad
guy that we see this is the dude that
you need the Avengers for on a big level
possibly twice in two back-to-back films
in order for him to be somebody that
serious he has to cause some major habit
uh Jason wouldn't rookie morante asking
what would be the Twist on the twist
when he says I don't have to win uh we
just both have to lose what will be the
Twist on the king will say it's a double
negative two loses make a win well I win
you make me think that if this king is
so powerful in the quantum realm if
Ant-Man lets him out does that make him
less powerful in a way now he can be
fine now he can be fought by someone in
the real world now right I mean
obviously can't escape well this one
could die in another king he might
understand that too yeah he might not
tell Scott that he might know about the
Multiverse again it wouldn't surprise me
if Kang understands about he who remains
Rama Tut iron lad Nathaniel Richards
immortus because if a mortise comes it's
over for everybody because mortise is
the worst version of Kane but maybe he
understands that and Scott doesn't
understand Scott just thinks this is
just the guy he was I was in prison here
who were you imprisoned by I was in
prison he never says a very of me Scott
doesn't understand all the multiversal
things yet we haven't heard anything
about multiverses with this yes
Spider-Man knows strange knows Loki
knows certain other people know about
Multiverse Scott hasn't been mentioned
it Shane she doesn't she doesn't even
know it so Scott has to realize oh it's
just one person Kane realizes you take
me out someone replaces me even worse
just like he who remains said if I go my
variants come and they're better than me
and they're worse than me they're worse
than me I mean he could be helping the
Kenya helps at the beginning might be a
good game and then when he comes back
he's like hey we had to do he's like oh
that was the other thing I killed that
gang I'm a different that game is Dead
that can't do that when he came through
down my street like the Canyon's dang it
along with the King uh world's biggest
how do you guys feel if this movie
introduces the famous first family as a
tease of them coming to stop the post
credit scene I I cannot be told that A
Fantastic Four is going to show up in a
post credits anymore all you have to do
is have it open up just to let them out
they don't have to show up like in full
it's just either it opens up and
something comes through and all you see
is a full stretchy arm a silhouette
something stretchy or something on fire
you don't have to fully see them it's
just a stretchy hey yo coming out at you
hey yo I'm saying that at a Canadian
strip club lots of things come out of
something strange
thank you those are some mighty fine
nipples
also asking was Ant-Man trying to go
lower than the quantum realm could that
be where Bill Murray is I don't know if
you can go lower subatomic subatomic
love lower and lower there was that part
in the First movie when it gets to like
all utter silence I don't know it would
be fun to return today
that's the best that's a Sunday
afternoon nap right there hey Marcel is
trying to to get in there by saying I
think Scott is dying is a smoke screen
I'm just pretty sure Hank or Janet is
dying thank you Michael Douglas or or
Michelle Pfeiffer doing this for long
they're going to hear that and they're
going to sign on for three more
do you all think we're gonna miss
minutes Cameo I don't think so she's
filming with uh Beauty and the Beast
crossover right now
yeah I love that person she got signed
to UTA yeah she's doing a crossover with
cogsworth uh absolutely stop I mean it
would be interesting if if Scotland's uh
gears in the chat what he has to do is
steal Miss minutes uh maybe he needs
her whole Essence Ladarius I believe
she's more than just remember he who
remains created her and she's more than
just this little I'm your little guy
through the TVA she's more than that so
she could be a part of this yeah uh Bill
uh Bill Theodore Roca yeah you said
I don't know saying the first trailer uh
the first trailer I had handling those
orbs in this trailer Scott is about to
fire a disc to miniaturize a larger
version of those orbs oh maybe like he's
gonna use his little oh the little
growing shrinking disc on those orbs
maybe I don't know the science behind
should your orbs work in a miniaturized
Quantum room Blaster things look like
Stark Tech almost that was very yeah I
mean we assume that's from his own
attack right tanks from the very far
future he just brings a bunch of it'd be
like us going back to the civil war with
a couple of hours
hey boys come on
we're all American come on North South
East and West it's all the same to me
when you turn the lights out you can't
tell the difference ladies yeah CSU
Eagle 117 going by their newly given
name Ebenezer splooge we apologize for
giving you that name cheers
uh what other Avengers could we possibly
see in quantumanium or we already said
shangshi we'll say shangshi yeah uh Wong
you gotta guarantee a Wong appearance
Hawkeye I've said it right here guys
coming down to the quantum realm oh you
go shoot some arrows and
my baby boy get him down there get him
down there I said what I said you meant
that with my chest I think weirdly
Batman
a variant of them maybe very in Batman I
think now there's Disney on Spotify
we're doing this for empty frog man
yeah that's hailee Steinfeld first
as herself not as her character not as
girl Hawkeyes uh Jesse Fair Bloom coming
in with a good point here Thanos said he
atomized the stones could have been sent
to the quantum yeah nice job
remember from that's possible but also
remember from the very what is it first
the second episode of Loki the amount of
freaking uh Infinity Stones in the TV
powered there right I mean here's the
thing I I like to think about I love to
think about this as I'm falling asleep
at night the stones Infinity Stones in
the 616 Adam yeah all dark holds gone in
every Universe they all exist anymore
they're gone they were all destroyed and
so the dark holes are gone but the
Infinity the book of Ashanti gone okay
okay the Infinity Stones the Russo
Brothers have said that like their
powers are so effective because they
were atomized but their powers exist in
the universe so there's just no physical
manifestation of them anymore maybe they
sprinkled down into the quantum realm
like a beautiful ring I mean they could
they they could be sucked down in there
or it's like a situation where yeah you
don't have these physical Stones don't
you do it again don't you make that
sound I'll put you on the corner to make
some money
so they're not physical but they still
have powers but they can't manipulate
anymore and now there's no magical books
to like create these barriers so this is
a weird 616 continues to be weird it was
also a universe that Ken couldn't get in
and maybe he didn't even see it before
he was blind to it but now it's like a
shiny Apple that he wants to take a look
yeah yeah get in because I would I would
think to I think I I always envisioned
that what he who remains was doing was
not like I put up these barriers to keep
the Kings out it's more like the Kings
can't see us we're drifting blind we're
sailing right behind Okay and now now
there's this like all these flashing
lights going off and now the kings are
like oh we haven't gotten to this one
yet I didn't know this one was there but
I think like with the stones my only
thought is the stones as if we found out
in Doctor Strange In in uh Avengers
Infinity War they're Elemental anyway so
when Thanos says he atomized him he just
probably returned them to the elements
in which they're from he didn't want
someone else to be able to yeah
their energy is just out here so again
six stones from six different points in
the elements can be brought back
together but I I mean again time is a
thing in itself no matter what what if
whatever you're preaching to me I agree
what if Kang needs all those Ant-Man to
each grab an atom of of a stone and put
it back together rebuild the stones
piece by piece but they're human Peace
by piece but they're human they can't
touch that's true that's true uh one
more real fast Francis again for them
they can't touch the stones Francis s
coming in late with a super chat hot
take what if Scott meant Kang when he
was in the quantum realm and Ken gave
him the Time Heist idea as part of a
deal before end game yeah and now Ken's
pissed he wants his money back yeah that
is an idea buddy hey not even a shout
out on the podcast
the Planet Queen three yeah hey I went
to Quantum jail you're living my life
just came in with me right she's like I
just did this other movie I don't think
it's gonna be as big as this
I think that could be good uh well thank
you folks for staying up late or waking
up early to join us on this late edition
of the break room after dark yeah thank
you all the super Chatters sending stuff
including uh Quinn Bucky Barnes
one John 138 a few others there uh I'm
gonna say it right Tito rocakos uh
we're gonna have lots more to talk about
uh with Ant-Man Quantum we're gonna go
through this trailer even more we gotta
watch it like 100 more times uh tune in
all week uh Tommy's gonna be working on
a Modoc video overnight and get it out
tomorrow morning uh so check out for
Tommy's Modoc video empty is gonna have
a breakdown of this trailer shop for
shot on Wednesday Whitney's gonna do a
video about cancer this weekend if you
learn more about her so much to talk
about we're so excited to have a little
more Ant-Man to watch Quantum hey man is
the game going
thank you internet uh thank you for
watching be sure to like And subscribe
if you haven't already and we'll catch
you back here tomorrow at our regular
time on the break room later skaters see
you later roomies bye
thank you
[Music]
foreign